(relaxing music)
- In the Netherlands, it rains a lot.
Since I grew up, the
weather is really changing.
It rains more, it rains more heavy,
and it's getting warmer as well.
People have a tendency to
complain about the weather.
I think it's beautiful
when you hear the rain,
it really changes pace,
and it also sustains growth.
I wanted to make something
to celebrate the weather.
Made-by-rain started
after I got the heritage
of my grandfather.
This heritage was a collection
of calendars
where he wrote down every
day the weather conditions.
When I was doing my master's,
I thinking, how can I
actually map the weather?
And then I started to doing
the same as my grandfather,
but then with textiles.
I made this technique,
pluviography,
which is drawing with rain.
There are two ways to make
made-by-rain textiles.
One I call analog version,
and one a digital version.
When I'm in The Hague at my studio
and it starts to rain,
I go up on the roof,
and for the analog version,
I use two layers of textile
and of ink with paper.
And when the rain hits the surface,
the paper gets wet,
and it starts to bleed,
so that makes it, the white
cloth becomes black or blue,
depending on the color.
The digital version is
prepared with a layer of ink
already on the cloth,
and when the rain hits the
surface, the ink starts to bleed.
After I put it in the rain,
I fixate the textiles,
and then you can wear it.
With this technique, you
can see every rain drop,
and every little detail in the rain.
So after I fixate my textiles,
I check the data from the weather station,
in order to really finalize the moment,
and the data, which is
silk-screened upon the textile.
With our data comes in statistics,
and I wanted to make a more visual way
of archiving weather.
On the textiles, I note the location,
the date, the time interval,
the millimeters of rain,
and the weather circumstances,
and I do this because I see
the textiles as documents,
so they're all unique.
Five minutes of drizzle is very different
than five minutes of heavy rainfall.
(exciting piano music)
I've hoped that with the
textiles that I make,
people get a new awareness of rain,
and a new relationship
with the environment.
I hope people see the beauty, as well.
Not only the pouring rain,
and waiting for it to be dry
to continue your daily life.